السعودية ولبنان إلى أين؟
هل تقاطع السعودية لبنان بسبب تصريح عابر لمواطن لبناني؟
ولماذا اختارت السعودية هذا التوقيت بالذات
لترد على تصريحات قرداحي؟
هل تريد التغطية على أخبار أخرى
مقابل تضرر الشعب اللبناني؟
وهل السعودية أساسا دخلت اليمن لتعينه وأعانته حقا؟
وعكس هذا السؤال..
هل دخلت السعودية حربا في العهد الجديد
منذ مطلع القرن ال٢١ وانتصرت؟
هل يعقل ذلك؟؟  السؤال بطريقة أخرى..
هل شاركت السعودية بدعم دولة أخرى في حربها
سواء بدعم مادي أو معنوي أو لوجستي أو عسكري
وانتصرت هذه الدولة؟ ؟؟.... فلماذا كل هذا العويل
بعد تصريحات قرداحي؟
أسئلة تطرح نفسها والإجابة في دقائق هذا الفيديو.
الرئيس الأمريكي السابق دونالد ترامب قال
(  نحن نعتبر السعودية بقرة حلوب)
لكن ما الذي كان سيحدث للسعودية لو جف حليبها؟....
في المقابل ردت السعودية، فماذا عملت؟
لقد ردت بضخ مليارات الدولارات في بنوك الولايات المتحدة..
لم يكتفي ترامب بذلك.. بل قال أيضا
(لولا حمايتنا للسعودية لما استطاع ملوكها البقاء على عروشهم لساعات)...
هذه المرة لم ترد السعودية احتراما لترامب وصراحته،
لكنها لم تقطع حليبها عن الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية بسبب تصريحات رئيسها..
مرّ بنا الزمان قليلا لنرى تصريحات قرداحي بأن حرب السعودية في اليمن عبثية...
وقال هذا رأي شخصي خاص بي.. لكن المملكة أرعدت وأزبدت وهددت
وقلبت الأرض عاليها أسفلها.. لكن لماذا؟ أ لأنه عربي؟
المملكة سحبت سفيرها من لبنان وطردت سفير لبنان...
لكن هذا لا يكفي بل تقطع الدعم عن لبنان وبالتالي فهناك بوادر
أزمة في الغذاء للبلد الضعيف لبنان؟ الذي لم يرفع سيفا على السعودية
ولم يطلق رصاصة باتجاهها؟ حتى أن لبنان أيضا نددت بتصريحات !قرداحي
وقالت أنه رأي شخصي لا يمت لها بصلة؟ لكن المملكة لا تسكت عمن أخطأ بحقها
ولنا أن نرى ذلك في ترامب وقرداحي...
يبدو أن تصريحات قرداحي لم تكن لتلقى هذه الضجة!
على الرغم من مضي أكثر شهرين على إطلاقها؟
لكن بعد خروج مسؤول الاستخبارات السعودي السابق سعد الجبري
بتصريحات نارية وخطيرة! متهما ابن سلمان على الملأ
(يقول الجبري أن ابن سلمان الأمير الصغير جلب خاتما مسمما من روسيا،
كي يقتل به الملك عبدالله حالما يسلم عليه بيده ويقبله قبلة الوداع،
لكن وبعد كشف الأمر وتوسط عدد من الأمراء تراجع عن ذلك؟)..
وهذا الحديث مصور بفيديو يتحدث به بن سلمان بحسب الجبري،
في الغرب هم متأكدون أن السعودية أقامت الدنيا ولم تقعدها بسبب قرداحي،
للتغطية على تصريحات الجبري... وهنا يخرج سؤال مهم،
هل كانت وفاة الملك عبدالله طبيعية؟
وماذا لو كان الملك سلمان بصحته الكاملة؟ هل كان الأمير الصغير
سيغتال أباه ليصل للعرش؟...
هل أصبحت السعودية تصب جام غضبها على من استطاعت من الدول الضعيفة
لتغطي بذلك على عجزها عن الدول ذات القوة؟ ..
ألم يخرج ترامب يوما ويقول أن الحرب في اليمن ليست إلا حرب عبثية لا طائل منها؟
ألم يصف ترامب المملكة بأنها دولة كرتونية؟
وقال أنه اتصل بملكها في وقت متأخر من الليل وجعله يستيقظ فورا
وأمره أن يرسل له المليارات من الدولارات فورا،
ثم قال لقد كان أخذ هذه المليارات أسهل علي من أخذ إيجار دكان في ولاية نيويورك،
فأين كانت المملكة يومها لترد على ترامب؟
بعد طرد السعودية لسفير لبنان لحقت بها الإمارات والبحرين والكويت
في مجاملة واضحة المعالم؟
لكن قطر اكتفت بالتنديد ولم تحرك ساكنا؟؟
يوم أن حاصرت السعودية قطر وجرت معها بقية دول الخليج
وفرضت بنودا على قطر لتفك عنها الحصار، ما الذي حدث؟
استمرت قطر بحياتها بشكل طبيعي، وفي النهاية كانت السعودية
من طلبت الصلح وخسرت حربها مع قطر الدولة الصغيرة التي لا يصل حجمها
لحجم محافظة سعودية، ..
فلماذا تفرد المملكة عضلاتها على لبنان؟ بسبب تصريح واحد؟
بل إن السعودية دعمت المعارضة السورية في حربها ضد النظام فخسرت؟
وحاربت ضد الأتراك في ليبيا وخسرت أيضا؟
ودخلت في حرب العراق وأفغانستان وخسرت بالطبع،
فما الحرب التي انتصرت بها المملكة على مدى العقود الأخيرة؟
وبعد هذا كله يخرج رئيس  هيئة الترفيه ومستشار ولي العهد (تركي آل الشيخ)
ويقول من الذي يجرؤ على مواجهتنا؟
أمرٌ مضحك حقاً..
(في الحقيقة يا سيادة الأمير فلا أحد يجرؤ على ذلك، ليس خوفا منكم
بل خوفا عليكم فقد خسرتم جميع مواجهاتكم وانتصرتم بأموالكم فقط
التي تبعثروها بين الشرق والغرب لإثارة الفتن وإشعال الحروب)...
بالعودة إلى اليمن فما الذي جنته السعودية من حرب اليمن؟،
لم تجن شيئا يذكر لكنها أذاقت اليمنيين ويلات حرب عبثية حقا
اليمن وبسبب الحرب السعودية العبثية أصبح يعاني من أسوأ أزمة إنسانية في العالم
وفقًا للأمم المتحدة إذ أنه على حافة المجاعة فيما سقط مئات آلاف القتلى
وشرد الملايين من النازحين ودمرت البنية التحتية،
والكثير والكثير من المصائب التي حلت باليمن لإشباع رغبة المملكة
بصرف أموالها على حرب اليمن ليس إلا!!!
كلمة الحق التي قالها جورج قرداحي أمام هذا السلطان الجائر،
تستغلها السعودية لتغطي على جرائمها، فإلى أين ستصل علاقة السعودية ولبنان؟
ومن بعدها علاقة المملكة باليمن وبالدول العربية عامة؟؟؟